thank you thank you for that thanks
earlier to Hannah thanks all of you for
being here
veterans I mean the all into you thirst
see me do these before we'll know that
I'm often in the habit of saying it's
the right time and the right place with
the right people for this debate well
I'm gonna use that line again tonight
because it's certainly the right time on
a day when handily you might say for the
prime minister the unemployment rate
fell to 7.1 percent and all the economic
indicators appear to be going in the
right direction so certainly those
numbers would suggest we've never had it
so good we're in the right place because
we are gathering in the Royal Borough of
Kensington and Chelsea which I think the
numbers suggest is the most affluent
borough in the entire country so you'll
all have never had it so good and we're
with the right people a stellar line-up
laid before you here all of whom I'm
sure would at least get through the
first round in that debating
championship against primary
schoolchildren so we've got four very
very good speakers who are going to
attack this subject you've all voted on
your way in I hope I will give you the
results of that indicative ballot if you
like later on once we've heard from our
four speakers and then you will vote
again once you've heard the four
inspiring arguments that are going to be
laid before you the rules are that they
each have about ten minutes to speak
I will ding or ping the glass at around
nine that's a signal for them to wind up
and I will start bashing the glass
repeatedly if they go beyond ten so
you'll hear that I'm sure and then
they'll be a chance for you to make your
own contributions I'm gonna ask for
really sharp short questions if we can
rather long speeches because you'll have
heard those already so without further
ado let's get to this live question for
the country we've never had it so good
is that right or is that wrong and first
up to make the case that we have never
it's so good his man who I'm sure would
like to be known as the biographer of
the great Edmund Burke who would like to
be known perhaps as the finest brain on
our back benches perhaps as the Member
of Parliament for he referred but is
perhaps fated to be known as the man who
dared square up to a red-faced David
Cameron in a Commons bar you will know
that he was the man who clashed as the
leader of a Tory rebellion against the
Prime Minister on the subject of Lords
reform with the Prime Minister
apparently poking in his direction and
telling him his behavior was not
honorable
I think it's an Eaton thing our first
speaker for the motion that we've never
had it so good Jesse Norman
well thank you very much indeed mr.
chairman especially if that tally
unnecessary reference to my screwing and
thank you ladies and gentlemen for
coming along today it's a fantastic
honor to be able to address the
collective wisdom of an intelligent
squared audience in such wonderful
circumstances and I'm particularly
honored to be able to tell you that I'm
teamed up as you will know with the
gorgeous the effervescent Rachel Johnson
I am simply the warm-up act for her
grand Aria ladies and gentlemen our tiny
canopy to the full smorgasbord
all-you-can-eat rhetorical feast of
johnson jana for those of you familiar
with Austin Powers I am a mere mini-me
to her Vanessa Kensington and while
we're on the topic of 1960s parodies
later on we may also welcome rod little
and will South
two men whose combined lugubrious nests
make MOOCs painting the scream look like
a frolicsome yodel with the faun trap
with the fur drop family in the hi outs
undoubtedly Liz gentlemen our offense
tonight will treat us all to numerous at
tales of gloom and doom there will be
lots of downward-pointing charts
predictions of catastrophe even
Armageddon all laced or laced with that
gritty with it lacerating social comedy
sorry commentary which you would expect
from a columnist at the spectator and a
past winner of the Bollinger everyman PG
Woodhouse prize Lesley Elrond is my
happy task tonight to propose a motion
that we've never had it so good
it's a clever twist on those famous
words repeatedly uttered by Harold
Macmillan in 1959 of course McMillan's
actual words were most of our people
have never had it so good and that was
true for the great mass of people in
work real pay had risen sharply in the
1950s but Macmillan had a deeper point
also it in mind that even for the
generations that had lived through the
Agony's the slaughter of the Second
World War in a country for which
rationing was a very recent memory it
was important to have some perspective
and to recognize that society was
renewing itself and that economic
recovery was underway and that by
implication the horrible sacrifices of
war were being redeemed now here today
we have an economy that is recovering
slowly as our Chairman has reminded us
from a great catastrophe but I want to
enter an early caveat with you if I may
a disclaimer then the motion says we've
never had it so good I want to ask who
is this we it would be absurd to suggest
that absolutely every single person in
the world or even everyone in Britain at
this particular moment was better off
than they ever
have been clearly at any given time
there will be some people and some
social groups for whom the most is not
true the England cricket team for
example let's gentleman recently
hammered in the ashes by the Australians
or Oh Francois Hollande who's had a
tough couple of weeks although I must
say you have to love a political system
in which even an accountant can get
lucky
how he must have wished he could get
away with it as his predecessors had
done notably of course Jacques Chirac
whose lovemaking skills earned him the
epithet tuam a newt douche conky I went
translated equally some people have done
better they might ever have imagined
while we're on the topic of sex how many
of you know Peter Crouch is that a
familiar name to an intelligent squared
audience a gentleman six foot eight
plays for Stoke City married to Abbey
Clancy
so one someone asked him recently what
he would have been if he hadn't been a
professional footballer to experience
halls a virgin
so Peters done a lot better I think it's
fair to say than he was expecting to do
some time ago but more seriously there
is a large group one large group in our
society who might very seriously
question the motion before us this
evening young people the the so-called
jutted generation with record levels of
youth unemployment high household debts
at a shortage of housing you can see why
many of them feel the baby boomers have
raided the till at their expense but
even this can be overstated in the last
50 years educational opportunity has
exploded in 1960 just twenty two
thousand people got an undergraduate
degree two years ago it was over 350,000
in 1960 it would be highly unusual for a
young person to go abroad today they are
everywhere from torremolinos to Timbuktu
in 1960 a telephone was affixed applied
often kept in the hall for those
families that had one today no young
person would be seen dead without the
latest iPhone or Samsung to text on so
the real question is this overall all
things considered has there been an era
in human history or even British history
when we could collectively rationally
prefer to be living than now and the
answer that question is no just look at
the facts over the past 50 years the
average per-capita income of the average
person on the on the planet wherever
they are in real terms adjusted for
inflation has gone up by a factor of
three three times lifespan is up by 30
percent child mortality is but down
two-thirds across the planet per-capita
food production is up by a third we are
a wildly innovative species and that
rate of innovation
is increasing polio used to kill or harm
millions of people every year today has
barely ceased to exist huge strides have
been made in combating malaria
we've even bred new strains of infertile
female mosquitoes which I must say a
hell of a lot easier than having to fit
all the male's with condoms
that's the joy of the division of labor
of Technology and of free markets that's
why this audience can leave tonight in
their foreign cars and eat hamburgers
pasta or sashimi for dinner none of
which was even imaginable five decades
ago this being an intelligent squared
audience of course to any of you who
might be made minded to vote against the
motion I say think of a world without
sashimi and take the position of women
today there are many countries in the
world in which the position of women is
still shamefully one of subservience and
abuse but who can doubt that in this
country indeed in many countries around
the world the position of women is
better now than it ever has been until
the second half of the 19th century
married women were essentially regarded
as their husband's property in this
country just fifty years ago before the
great white goods revolution most
women's lives were dominated by domestic
chores you may feel not much has changed
but it has the statistics tell us now
those the situation is far from perfect
today more than ever before women have a
world of educational and life
opportunity before them now that does
not mean that everything is rosy far
from it things are hardly perfect now
look at the financial crisis we've just
had to endure history is not always an
unbroken progression of towards freedom
and prosperity technology has massively
enriched us but we live under a shadow
and that shadow whether it be
environmental change terrorism or
nuclear holocaust will continue to hang
over us democracy itself is struggling
as politics becomes apparently ever
further removed from people's everyday
lives and of course we've had colossal
failures inside and outside of
government as we have had ever since
government itself was invented we have
to keep asking why and working to make
sure that we never repeat those mistakes
though we know in advance that we will
moral principles and moral values do not
change and it's our obligation as a
present generation the obligation of all
of us not just of those in positions of
authority to ask in a deep and
considered way how those principles can
best be applied to help others to
protect and sustain
our society for the benefit of future
generations ladies and gentlemen we have
never had it so good
and it's precisely because we've never
had it so good because we've had that
priceless privilege of being born when
we were born that we owe this obligation
now to others so I submit to you then
the facts are absolutely clear in the
facts name I ask you to ignore the gloom
stirs the naysayers the professional
miserable lists the Jeremiah's the
pessimists and above all to support the
motion thank you very much indeed
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much to Jesse
Norman our next speaker I don't know
whether he includes a gloom store or
professional miserable list on his
business card but he certainly could put
their acclaimed novelist journalist and
broadcaster a past Booker Prize nominee
and the man who among whose many claims
the famous to have made the phrase epi
phenomenal imbroglio trend on Twitter
and other social media in a TV
discussion of hacking to argue against
the motion the first speaker against the
motion that we have never had it so good
please welcome will self
[Applause]
[Applause]
men and women it's not customary at
debates of this sort to stoop to ad
hominem remarks we argue things as
intelligent conscientious people on the
basis of the arguments themselves not on
the basis of stereotyping the nature of
our debating opponents but that being
said Richard Strauss's
for last songs are some of the most
beautiful leader in my opinion that have
ever been written and I came here this
evening purely on the understanding that
Jesse Norman would be singing
I am bitterly disappointed to have
instead heard the sort of second-rate
piffle
the comes out of any Tory MPs mouth when
you prod them in the belly tears are
running down the insides of my eyes but
I'm too big a man to show it and I will
turn my attention to the motion we've
never had it so good is the motion
contra what mr. Norman said cleverly
trying to shift the goal posts but in my
opinion not really managing to shift
them that far
most statements in language are by
definition semantics statements they're
statements about meaning on that basis I
would like to dispute not just the
motion but every single term in the
motion my argument is not going to be
about statistics or perceptions this
would be an insult to you as an audience
my argument will be about the meaning of
this motion and on that basis I
anticipate that you will agree with what
I say and vote it down and the reason
you will vote it down is because the
motion treats you purely as a member of
a spurious collectivity we've never had
it so good
doctors say that in medicine there are
no such things as statistics only
individuals and in the unfortunate event
that you were diagnosed for the terminal
illness I think you will feel the full
force of those words why should we be a
we at all recall one of the most
chilling futuristic novels about
totalitarian society was called simply
we by yo Venu Sammy Yatim
a pitcher of a ghastly society in which
vast phalanxes of people were compelled
to go about their business treated as an
undifferentiated mass by subscribing to
the we in we've never had it so good
you're placing yourself in the same
framework ours is a political culture
that is based on a calculus of benefit
we've never had it so good the principal
ideologue of British society is Jeremy
Bentham and his utilitarianism which
puts forward the idea that the aim of
society should be to achieve the
greatest good stroke happiness of the
greatest number but I put it to you that
is precisely this Benthamite ideology
that dara gates the individual and
removes the individual from her
immediate experience and alienates her
from the social and political process
we've never had it so good let's have a
little look at never for a while
let's go to never-never land how do you
know how do you know can you look inside
the thoughts and feelings and emotions
of your spouse for many years who is
sitting right next to you at this moment
and has vast areas of their soul that
are effectively walled off from you and
yet and I wouldn't have it any other way
what would be the point participating in
a relationship with anybody who is
entirely legible to you none whatsoever
we've never had it so good we these
people who know so little of each other
this we've never is an extension of a
tyrannous subjectivity over not only the
person sitting next to you but the
entire room and in the context and the
feeling of the motion the entire society
and yes by implication the entire globe
I promise you no statistics
no numbers and I won't give you any but
take the utilitarian philosophy where it
leads you and it tells you that human
increase can only be a good thing after
all there's so much more good to be have
when there are more of us yeah
so on the utilitarian calculus we'll be
in really good shape when all day every
day
we're packed in just as tightly as we
are in this hall then we'll really never
have had it so good
this is not a specious argument it is
indeed the underlying prolegomena of the
EULA Tillett Aryan position it's an
endless yey saying two more of
everything it's an endless yey saying to
knowing the cost of everything because
cost can be quantified and Bentham love
to quantify but you can't cost the real
value of life just as you cannot know
what other people are thinking and
feeling and philosophies that base
themselves on such specious
quantification throw up specious
demagogues it's up to us to be
individuals to discover our own nature
of the good and to respect other
people's idea of the good as well and
not treat them as simply people on a
production line or in a factory Jonathan
Frieden began by referring to economic
statistics aren't you bored with them
don't you known every time you hear one
pronounced ours has become a culture in
which economic statistics have a fashion
and have you noticed those of us who are
my age or older Quinn cogent Aryans when
we were younger it was something called
the balance of payments deficit people
were worried about you don't hear much
about that anymore the difference
between the value of what we export and
what we import what you hear about now
is consumer demand consumer demand you
could have no more telling example of
what our society has become how soulless
our society has become then that it
measures its moral and spiritual health
on the basis of whether it's buying in
[ __ ] I don't want to make a big deal
about this you may have noticed one
other thing besides my lugubrious voice
in my lugubrious face which hides a
happy soul a happy agnostic soul who's
happy to live in a world in which there
may well be a god and that is that I
came here this evening with no notes and
no prepared speech because I believe in
what I say so I ask you to reject the
motion and recover your soul
[Applause]
Thank you very thank you - thanks very
much that those of you playing will self
bingo I wonder how many of you had
quincannon Aryan or Quinn Quinn Oh Jared
it wasn't on my list but tremendous so
we move now to our next speaker the who
will be the second speaker for the
motion the former editor of the lady
magazine journalist who writes a weekly
column for The Mail on Sunday and the
big issue and the author of novels
Notting Hill and Shire he'll I'm sure
popular reading in this audience and has
spent the last week in rather intriguing
fashion which I hope she'll share with
you please welcome to speak for the
motion that we've never had it so good
Rachel Johnson
Jonathan thank you very much for your
introduction it's always nice to come to
the podium and not to be introduced as
the sister of somebody and it reminds me
that for several years the Evening
Standard only referred to me as the
penis obsessed sister of Boris despite
my best efforts but I suppose we all
have our stuff that we can't
successfully get rid of as Charlie
Brooks might think when as he tried to
dispose of his carefully created
collection of lesbian porn we have heard
from Jesse we are going to hear from rod
as the Bible says and there shall come
forth a rod out of the stem of Jesse
which means I think it is my turn
I'm afraid to take the floor and to
regale you with some statistics and I
hope punctually convince you of the
argument that despite what our Jeremiah
says we have never had it so good I know
that Jesse took some of his much reviled
statistics from a book called the
rational optimist by Matt Ridley which
I'm going to credit as I don't think
Jesse did Jesse is that fair and as
we're on the subject of Matt Ridley let
mean that's just posed to consider how
in one man we have an embodiment of
somebody who on the inner terms of
personal developmental growth has really
had it very good a man who brought down
northern rock now has a column on the
times of I can't see a seat in the
Lord's whose estates in Northumberland
roll over thousands of acres and who's
about to make many more millions from
fracking in one man we can see that it
is possible in this country to have it
pretty good but moving beyond Matt
Ridley for a sec
and on to his statistics 99% of
Americans officially designated as poor
have running water lose and a fridge 95%
have TVs I know this is these are things
that people like to have in their lives
we'll even though they are evidence of
consumption which is clearly a bad thing
in your book we are becoming richer by
these statistics that my colleague and
panelists Jesse Norman stated and oh we
have cleaner freer richer even cleverer
apparently there's something called a
leveling up caused by an equalization of
nutrition stimulation and diversity of
childhood experience way-hey
exactly we're also becoming a less
violent Society there's a book by Steven
Pinker that I was encouraged to read by
Hannah Kay who's our genius genius lucky
tonight in which Steven Pinker claims we
are even winning the war on war I would
conclude my opening remarks by saying
that if you vote for homage and your
wife will get bigger even bigger breasts
and it's much more likely that you will
end up driving a BMW but those remarks
would be unseemly and such a polite
society as the RGS I hear you all
thinking about will selfs remarks that
all this consumption is bad or this
growth all these widescreen TVs all this
sky TV is a human rights as a human
right even on benefit Street and I agree
the better things are for man the worse
they tend to be for the planet I accept
that these are the two trump cards are
pessimists the apakah holics always
produce climate change Africa I predict
actually I don't predict because I don't
know about what words gonna say but
we're not debating climate change in
Africa
and if we were I would have to point out
to you that our air rivers lakes and
seas are much cleaner than they were and
in even in America carbon monoxide
emissions are 75 percent down on 75
years ago and I would also have to point
out that rod little him
self as a climate change denier is that
right rod yes it is yes it is
you just mocked the prime minister for
saying that our recent nasty weather was
the result of global warming rather than
for example that what you could any fool
in you kept knows which is it's a result
of obviously his decision to legalize
gay marriage didn't you no yes you did
you say that global warming is basically
just the abnormal operating system for
winter so let us take what I presume
will be rods line about climate change
forget about our good luck with that
button and return to the motion so we're
here to show that for man if not for the
planet things are getting better all the
time but we would be stupid to ignore
some economic statistics and hard truths
the public finances are as will self
might put it shot to [ __ ] as even and we
have Alister Dallas it Alistair Darling
told us the other day it's going to get
worse you can feel it Edie tripled it
balls would like us to think there's no
Jam tomorrow and soon in fact we're all
going to be living in the gulag of
Britannia but the economy is growing
we've had unemployment seven point one
percent and we are growing faster than
any other major economy and as David
Cameron said in his New Year message I
want to look at will sells fairly face
as I write to quote what new David
Cameron's new year message our country
is on the rise
completely impassive oh well anyway
David Cameron knows too much optimism is
even toxic for the Tories because he
wants us to vote for him for fear of
finding something worse in the eds
woodshed okay let's move on though this
cut this generation has left the next
generation in hock but we can't cry too
much into our frothy Nespresso lattice
here's why Jeremy Warner wrote in a
Telugu
Blagh stop whinging even the young have
never had it so good
quit I'm mark reaching in case of
plagiarism repeated foreign holidays
conspicuous consumption and all the
creature comforts under the Sun and no
longer the exclusive preserve of the
privileged few
many of the young enjoy lifestyles their
parents could only dream of at a similar
age he also pointed out that wealth is
eventually recycled to younger
generations either because it is
squandered because it's inherited or
taxed Jonathan mentioned that I've been
somewhere what did you say intriguing so
if I see him a bit below par it's
because for the last seven days I've
been living on one pound a day for the
purposes of a BBC documentary within
some of the two poorest boroughs in
Britain and the exercise was designed to
prove whether those in benefits really
are living high on the hog which is
quite a live topic at the moment and I
found the opposite I would live to in
two households both were in the grip of
diarist food poverty these households
out fix outgoings on energy on their
debts on rent on everything on fixed
costs left them with I promise you only
three pounds a day each to spend per
family on food I also found that these
deep cuts to the welfare state that were
across the board have led and I can't
believe I'm saying this to some
resurgence in what used to be called
until this notion was dispensed with big
society
I found an outpouring of compassion a
metal woman called Diane in
clacton-on-sea
now I know this sounds like Dave Cameron
saying I once met a black man in
Portsmouth but do bear with me she fed
dozens of people every day dozens of the
homeless and the hungry and she was
badgering local supermarkets to do
eat food rather than throw it away
because that's what they like to do so
she could start a food bank it was as if
I had a walk on part in lame miserable
only this time it was directed by
Richard Curtis because honestly the love
was all around her I'm getting emotional
now because there were soup kitchens
food banks Samaritans night shelters
churches Muslim support centres free
blankets you could get your clothes
washed you could see an advisor about
trying to find out whether your why your
housing benefit or being cuttle you're
being sanctioned you could go online to
look for a job and this is all not run
by the state by the voluntary sector now
I know not all on benefits are deserving
as we've seen from benefit Street but
all the adults I met wanted to work but
couldn't because they had criminal
records they had disabilities they had
children they couldn't afford the child
care but still I found no one too sick
or too bonkers or too foreign to be
helped by someone or at least filmed by
a channel 4 TV crew
I'm not saying big society has replaced
the state it hasn't and it shouldn't but
we need and we have both in this country
which is more than I can say for most
other places finally I'd like to turn to
the economy I know it's dull but as G K
Chesterton said the problem with
capitalism is not that there are too
many capitalists but not enough
capitalists we've seen the economic
statistics today but there is better to
come I've mentioned one brother my other
brother Leo has written a book called
turn around challenge and he has advised
me to tell you this in his brilliant new
book turn around challenge which is on
my chair Jonathan can you hold it up
please
hold up Leo Johnson uber o u P 20 pounds
what he tells me is this and I can't
claim I thought this myself unlike well
he says we will see a surgeon
capitalists as micro production returns
and new technologies come on stream bear
with me quote Chinese labor costs are
rising whereas the costs for micro
manufacturing and technologies like the
RepRap open-source 3d printer have the
potential to grow exponentially pushes
prices down pushing prices down further
what this means is really important
Chinese labor costs rising British labor
costs are falling British late that
means we are going to be competitive
again Leo told me in a text pot noodle
Otis Elevator caterpillar GE all
reshoring bringing production back to
Britain the future is local and a return
to local manufacturing is imminent so I
would say information our grounds for
optimism are anchored in the past we are
seeing think of me on benefit Street
think of Leo's pot noodles we are seeing
a return to two things in society that
we know well homo Faber manners creator
and man as a social animal big society
coming in where the state the state's
hand doesn't reach far enough to keep
them are safe the distributed economy
jaws are inst on our instinct not just
to create but to look after each other
whether from the top down or the bottom
up in some I would say please do not buy
rod littles forthcoming box set of doom
I beg to propose the motion
[Applause]
I hope I hope the record shows and all
of you have witnessed that I was very
right on sound and garden ish and
refused to define a woman by her
brothers and that she they mentioned not
one not two but three of them in oh did
you mention two I thought I thought a
joke or dimension but maybe that was
implicit
okay I've between the lines I thought
there was a third there anyway we move
on to our final speaker against the
motion
he began was a former editor of BBC
Radio 4's Today program where he was
professionally required to repress his
opinions and be studiedly neutral and
boy has he made up for it since he is
now an author and journalist who writes
a regular column for The Sunday Times
The Spectator magazine and the son
speaking against the motion please
welcome rod Biddle
[Applause]
thanks a lot Johnny thanks thanks for
that mate the problem I have is that
intuitively I feel I ought to agree with
the proposition because after all while
it may be that the gulf between rich and
poor is larger than at any time since
the War of the Roses and that executive
pay is an ever increasing multiple of
the money earned by people on the shop
floor and that those people on the shop
floor AB debt squatting on their backs
like a vast toad and all these other
indicators of economic inequality which
suggests that the rich are getting
richer and the poor are being robbed
blind at least today we have the right
people running the country after decades
of a futile experiment obsessed by that
chimera of social mobility we have at
last wisely succumbed in a once again
led by the same sorts of people who led
us at the time of Lord Salisbury when
Britain was at its zenith not just the
politicians although of course had
pre-eminent amongst this group but
everywhere there is money to be made or
power to be had in the judiciary in the
City of London in journalism the 7% of
the country who attended public schools
and the best public schools occupy up to
80% of the top jobs and indeed comprise
all of my fellow panelists didn't he
ohyou're anyway know you're on my side
and the moderator and the organizer
quite rightly as well quite rightly
they're in charge and is largely these
people these wonderful people who tell
us repeatedly that we have never had it
so good and they also tell us smiling
out of their shiny faces that we've
never had it so good and we're all in it
together so I think it would simply be
have me to agree and move on ever
upwards a simple answer to whether we've
ever had it so good we being the country
as a whole is to ask how happy people
are and the simple answer to that
question are we happy now to look inside
those souls which rule was talking about
it's of course that we're not we know
this because various studies including
one commissioned by the BBC have asked
if people are happy and far fewer admit
to this state of mind than did so in the
1950s when we were played to his rickets
smallpox and Sir Anthony Eden I have
some misgivings about these studies of
happiness the whole idea came of a gross
national happiness index was dreamed up
by Bouton's dragon king legally Cindy
wine-shop in 1972 largely I think as a
means of assuring his citizens that
whilst they were impecunious peasants
clinging to the side of a mountain and
subsisting on a diet of yaks milk while
being presided over by an obese autocrat
who thought he was a dragon they were
nonetheless overflowing with great
bonhomie and merriment
more recently the un's done the same
sort of study and into happiness and
invariably the Danes always come out top
they have many admirable qualities the
Danes but they're also singularly
gullible and deluded people indeed it
may well be the case of the Danes are in
a constant state of euphoria simply
because they are not Swedish
anyway Britain does very badly in this
index of happiness thing we come at the
bottom a more reliable means of testing
whether we are happy or not is to see
how many of us are depressed one in two
of us according to the latest report one
in two of us that never used to be the
case
I don't know how reliable the figures
are but it certainly seems to be a theme
of our time that increasing numbers of
others are afflicted by one or another
kind of existential despair or misery
we have seen the growth of mysterious
illnesses difficult to define such as
Emmy yup he flew as it was once called
and fibromyalgia that peculiar fliction
which apparently results in debilitating
aches and pains a million of us have any
or fibromyalgia apparently the symptoms
of these two illnesses along with
depression are lethargy lassitude
melancholy irritability and inability to
sleep an inability to rise a perpetual
sense of torpor and dissatisfaction
there are expressions you might argue of
an alienation or an enemy or an
atomization our doctors clinics and our
A&E walls are full of another new
phenomenon the worried well people who
are simply anxious and deeply unhappy
and then before all that distress stress
now accounts for the largest single
number of days people take off work
there are lots of different figures
around the latest I've seen from the
Health and Safety Executive puts a
number at 105 million days lost per year
75 percent of us say we suffer from
stress and this stuff this sort of
despair this sort of misery is as
defining about times as an Xbox or a
politician with his hand in your wallet
we simply didn't have this before and we
will note that in all cases it's a
frustration and an annoyance or in
extreme cases a pure loathing of society
or the stuff of society even with stress
where the ailment is most popularly
assigned to an imposition placed upon
the individual by an external agency
usually the employer one commentator I
forget who suggested rather callously
when presented with
a list of the symptoms of Emmie that
these people were suffering from nothing
more than quotes life well indeed and if
that is the case and demi is not the
consequence of a retrovirus which by now
even be pretty clear it isn't then over
here in this country we have life wrong
where's it all come from this stuff my
own suspicion is that it's been imposed
upon us by a system which certainly
ensures that a small number of people
the people I'd mentioned earlier have
never had it so good for example it's
not merely that wage rates are
criminally low and have been dropping
comparatively for years and that for
millions of us working for a living does
not provide nearly enough to get by
it is also the uncertainty of that work
it's the short term contracts the
temporary work the zero hour contracts
the complete absence for many millions
of working people of security of
employment of a predictable future still
less of that old discredited thing a job
for life which is now used in a derive
sense and the trouble is that as human
beings we like predictability and we
like security but the new working
patency unlimited free movement of
labour and capital imposes on us a
fraught and frenetic transience a
short-term contract ends when we chase
down the next one which may be a hundred
miles away we get on our bikes just as
his Locke told us to do 25 years ago and
then that contract ends and we're off
again and we do so with increasing haste
because we're assured by the people who
have never had it so good that if we do
not put our skates on and chase that job
down don't you worry mate
there'll be 250,000 people entering the
country within the year every year who
will do it quicker than you and a hell
of a lot cheaper than you and they tell
us this under the guise of enlightened
liberal internationalism just in case we
might complain and so we chase at the
behest of those who have never had it so
good
paid less and less comparative
comparatively every time
never sure when or even if the next job
is going to come up or how long it will
last unless a knock on the amount of
time we spend in any one place is
contracted and contracted over the last
25 years to the point where only one in
five of us now know who our neighbors
are anymore and we don't put down roots
in a community our neighbor now is
simply someone we shove out the way to
get on the bus of a morning it's a sort
of rival and remember our houses our
very houses are not homes anymore
they're no longer solid things in which
we raise a family and become part of a
community they are instead or they have
become a liquid a form of collateral to
be flogged so that we can move on and
pursue an illusion of affluence because
that's what it is an illusion of course
we are empowered by the people who have
never had it so good in everything these
days as we'll rightly pointed out we are
consumers customers and we are empowered
by choice endless endless choice about
everything where to send the kids to
school for example 12 local schools all
competing against each other for your
brats and who knows maybe you'll get
them into that half-decent Church of
England school if you rent a temporary
flat by the school gates and maybe for
late the vicar
when you're suffering from cancer you
are empowered by choice you're empowered
to troll through and find the best
available treatment even though you may
not know what the hell you are looking
for should you get your foreign-owned
water company to provide your
electricity or should you stick with the
foreign-owned gas company to provide
your electricity it doesn't matter a
bugger they're all part of the same
cartel which has just put up your
Terrace by for time of the inflation
rate but you've searched you search
because you're empowered to do so this
superfluous choice is endless
remorseless choice which we are enjoying
to believe is a good thing but it's not
it's a con job all of it is a con job it
is an illusion of empowerment and it is
an illusion of affluence as anyone who
when they look at their mortgage
statements will be able to tell you and
that's why we have to reject this motion
it's no surprise that in the current
system operating under the current way
we are forced to live at the moment that
we are ill and unhappy depressed
stressed-out ill with it all we've
swapped the communitarian for the
remorselessly individualistic at the
behest of an economic system which is
alienating and dehumanizing and it's
hardly a surprise as a corollary that we
have also disengaged in increasing
numbers from the political process since
1992 these days increasing numbers of us
either don't vote at all or we vote way
way beyond the mainstream and we feel as
a consequence disenchanted and powerless
and it's this system which does indeed
nonetheless benefit a small tranche of
our population
that trance which will from time to time
shot out that old sweet lie we're all in
it together and we've never had it so
good thank you
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
well as promised you've heard for
sparkling speeches there from this end
of the room and before we do throw it
open and before I give you the results
of the you're voting as you came into
the room let me just see if I can press
our full speakers just for the question
to each of them just to clarify some
points now I'm going to begin with our
first week at Jesse Norman and I just
you know you've sketched a picture there
of how we've never had it so good answer
this now the statistics are that there
are 500,000 people in the country in the
country using food banks and the
majority of those in poverty is said to
be working the figures when the
coalition took office were less than
1/10 of that numbered around 40,000
people were relying on food banks and
now it's half a million given that leap
how can you say we've never had it so
good well as you know Jonathan I wasn't
and creating specific facts about where
we are now and there's nothing that
anyone should take any pleasure out of
or anything other than you know a
feeling of gloom and sadness about the
situation with food banks the truth of
the matter is that it has been rising
literally exponentially for about 15
years now and it is not a new phenomenon
but the numbers are new and no one
really knows what the drivers of it are
although it has obviously money to pay
you for food no no no no of course of
course that's true but there are also
there was also question of whether or
not those people were as it were finding
informal ways of getting food before and
and I go to food banks so the question
is what's the actual you know is the
sizable from appropriately where does it
probably show us what it is and of
course we don't know and that's why I
think more more reflection on it and and
frankly anyone can deny that the
economic crisis were really is a is a
part of it and therefore hopefully a
recovery will pull these people out of
that situation
thank you something to you will self and
you made the point that this is
something unknowable we can't know how
the how the lives of others are lived
can't gaze into their souls but just an
obviously that's true about people's
inner lives and emotionally but
materially would you concede some of the
points have been
on this side of the table that in just
in terms of material well-being that
we've never had it so good
I think he died of a dick doctor from
India once said to me only in the West
is the term psychosomatic an insult mind
and the body are one I refused to answer
the question it's a meaningless to me in
the context of my argument I argue for
the whole woman and the whole man I
argue for us as spiritual beings are our
spiritual lives not made possible though
if people have a roof over their head
their houses are warm and they are able
to move around these are really but
these are all clearly destoroyah but I
draw your attention to my honorable
seconder here who I think did a very
good job on that front of showing that
we the correlation between absolute
material situation and mental and
spiritual health is not proven at all
and then let's just talk about this
tricky concept of relative poverty yeah
because that's what we seem to be
skirting around here the some notion of
borer abroad and afoot in our society
that you know as long as you can watch
TV and buy a can of extra-strength lager
that you've got nothing to complain
about in some way and you're saying that
that's a bogus notion because even if
materially you have more here than you
would if you were living in other parts
of the world where they don't have those
basics that doesn't go to house well
it's a mystery it's a mystery to me why
these extremely wealthy people in the
city really need their vast bonuses if
they don't believe in relative poverty
all right because stop they quite neat
clearly don't need to be relatively
wealthier yeah duh
thank you I just think you'd be the
professor of contemporary thought the
e/m let's put it to you Rachel Rachel
Jones let's put to you this thing what
you send it from your own experience of
the last week the people of the Euro
among were living on their three pounds
left over to feed their families given
the oral direct experience of that
number how can you stand up and say
they've never had it so good well in
1957 when how woman and said we've never
had it so good a man who was in
employment with three children it was in
real terms worse off than somebody who
is unemployed today on benefit with
three children with the child tax
credits and the child benefits which
accrued to him and his family so it's
again it's completely relative yeah
exactly
sure and finally to you before we have
now trod a little and you talked about
those people who were very squeezed and
pressed at the bottom people living on
zero hours being secure and the stressed
out for everyone else and you know will
self introduce the notion that you've
been to my utilitarian calculation for
everybody else would you concede any
ground there and say those people and
you're right it's not Universal but for
those people who they have never had it
so good and it's the people in the
bottom who are being left out or is your
picture across the whole country it's
across her well it's certainly it's
outside London largely which is
something which often seems to be
forgotten once you do go outside London
you see that the principal form of
employment are Pound shops door-to-door
selling these are things which generate
almost no income for the people who do
them they're usually on less than
minimum wages because they're on shorter
hours and the firm's could get away with
paying them less less than the minimum
wages of consequence it is a vast vast
number of people I think the middle
class sometimes Deleuze itself that it's
well off I don't know that it is quite
as well off as it thinks it is and we
will see that when
when when the next property slump comes
around thank you and let's give you the
results of the of your voters you came
in and this is just before you'd managed
to be swayed by any of the arguments
those of you who were for the motion
that we've never had it so good were 47%
so nearly half the room was with this
side of the table those against the
motion disagree that we've never had it
so good
24 percent with this side of the table
and then those who would don't knows 29%
so nearly a third of the room was on the
fence and it is those 29% that I say to
you both sides it's up to you to try and
persuade them win them over to your side
let's now open it all up and here's
questions thoughts contributions the
Pythia and sharper the better and let's
see some hands go up so if we've got a
hand over there and what I'll do is I'll
make sure there's my crane to play
things to you and is there a third mic
food anyone over here wants to say
anything because we have a microphone in
there for you yes maybe there so if we
can get those three Micron's in position
and I've noticed that people up there
let's start with it first here yeah do I
need to give my name nope my heroes
that's all you're gonna say is be my
hero rod little has argued that it's
only a privileged few who have never had
it so good I would argue from a long
lifetime of experience that oddly enough
there is a disadvantaged view or even
perhaps disadvantage many who have never
had it so good I mean the people in our
society who have mental illnesses mental
impairments and disabilities when I was
growing up and I've got long years of
personal experience of this people with
these disabilities were sneered at
excluded put to one side ignored and
disrespected all my life and that you
know rather elder but I'd like to be now
this isn't improving people have been
offered more respect this is not to do
with money although there has been much
more money offered to help people
generally speaking Rooker it's a big
cultural change for the better
so this disadvantaged group of people
has never had it so good thank you so
different angle on debate weren't very
much appreciated let's go to the speaker
up here questioner Rp
in defense of Jeremy Bentham we are
bodies and cells but by the same token
if you help the body you do help the
soul and I'm struck that the idea of a
cancer diagnosis has haunted this
discussion and a very close relative of
mine has recently been diagnosed with
cancer and I ask you all to believe that
it's extremely devastating for me but I
think that the same person was diagnosed
20 years ago with high blood pressure
which in the 19th century will probably
have killed her was diagnosed 15 years
ago with thyroid problems which perhaps
50 years ago would have killed her and
so even though I'm in the throes of
grief I have to confess you I do think
that in the broader sense it would be
selfish of me not to realize that we
have never had it so that in some
respects thank you thanks for speaking
so personally about your experience okay
thank you so both of those contributors
saying that if sort of medical reasons
that there have been advances that mean
we've never had it so good somebody's
waiting here with a contribution I yeah
well first of all support democracy in
Ukraine please secondly I've never had
it so good because 20 years ago I was
starving as a student in Ukraine and
today after a long work day at the bank
I came here to this debate so don't
really have a question just wanted to
say to read little who mentioned
immigration and passing that I'm already
here and I'm after his job his house and
his chewing gum
the lady said she's only been here a
year but is already after his job his
house and he's chewing gum
I don't want conclusions you can draw
but virtually two people on this side of
the table have been chewing their way
through nicotine gum
and that may say something about this
side of the Ogron you may say nothing
dude questioner here yeah right yes I
must say I'm grateful for the rod little
and will sell I've never ever heard such
depressing words from anybody in my
whole life and I think if the whole
world felt and spoke the way you do we'd
all be in trouble I mean it it really is
horrible to listen to that's not the
same as really but that's not the same
as same Iran will sing Sahara has had a
privileged education which he well knows
went as one of the finest universities
in the world and I think just sort of
sit there and be gloomy about everything
does that really help anybody is that
really a relation of how you exception
to what you're saying I'm not in the
least bit gloomy I'm a very very happy
person I think I think the stars are
God's daisy chain and daffodils the
souls of dead bunny rabbits and I get up
in the morning and I skip about the
place I'm a very active fulfilled man
nothing I said would imply that I was
gloomy or depressed what makes me gloomy
and depressed is the cheese pairing bean
counters who inhabit the other side of
this nation though I think I made that
perfectly clear
thank you why don't you finish
I conclude the point sharply and then
will come at any step are you the person
who started the big oh she was on a
panel that I was with some time ago and
he said when when asked the question
about salaries and he made the point
which is true he said we really need
these people who earn a lot of money
they produce employment for people they
pay half their money back at least in
taxation and most important of all they
spend the money most of them and the
spending it creates employment you
cannot alleviate poverty without
prosperity ok that's why we need the
people good I'm going to just take a
couple more because a lot of these have
been sort of comments rather than
questions and then but I want to get a
couple of questions we can bring back
here so gentleman up there then person
there and then we bring you here yeah
the speakers of forth emotion discussed
the improvements of science of
Technology in the past century that
reminds me of a quote by Isaac Asimov
who said the saddest thing in life right
now is that no science gathers knowledge
faster than society gathers wisdom I
would like to ask the panel for their
opinion to please
okay thank you don't wanna I've got all
of these and then we're gonna just take
one here that I've got questions about
yeah we must surely acknowledge
fantastic progress in the last 50 years
reduction in prejudice the gains and
medical science all of that stuff must
be acknowledged but surely rod and will
make the key point that the agenda is
terribly restricted while our
politicians continued to define progress
only by the amount that we consume the
amount that we have the amount of growth
that there is I've been in the food
industry for 40 years it's a good
example 30 40 years ago 30 percent of
household income was spent on food for
most of the last decade we spent 10
percent of our income on food and yet
half of us are fat and 30% of us are
obese and half the world is starving you
know there has to be an agenda that's
beyond simply consuming more and more
good things thank you let's
pause there pause there
I will no this time we will take another
round of questions but let's put these
straight away to you then so Jesse
Norman it's come you know will self
talked about cheese pairing bean
counters gentlemen they're saying that
we have to define a kind of notion of
the good life and have happiness that is
just beyond what we can see well I
couldn't agree more I mean I've just
written a book of the path the purpose
of which in part is to argue for
precisely this conception of human
flourishing I mean the the fact that
matter is that this is my BA graffia and
one of the things that Bert the point
the Burke's make is actually in advance
of Bentham is that a human life based on
a rational economic calculus as a in a
purely individualistic sense is a life
devoid of purpose or meaning and that
it's in our ability to join with others
and to find our identity in a collective
projects and in therefore in society in
social order and that's the linking
thought behind my call in my speech for
a proper understanding of the benefits
the privileges of being in society and
the obligations that go with that so I'm
absolutely not in the cheese pairing
place that I've been placed by the
opposition and in fact the opposite is
true if you look at the evidence what
people need is a sense of moral purpose
and some lenses is provided through
religion but not necessarily and moral
community and when they have that that
is a crucial element in their own
personal well-being and personal and
therefore we're more than ever
understanding the limitations of a
purely economic calculus so I would
absolutely associate myself with that
view and I wish we had a politics that
recognized these sources of wisdom and
recognized words that we that respect
that wisdom words like loyalty and
respect and honor the teams have dropped
out of the political lexicon altogether
Ron little let's put to you the he came
up in several different places several
different ways several different ways
that there have been advances in science
in medicine and particularly in
attitudes that prejudices attitudes to
those with mental health problems all of
these things count as real advances and
in those senses we've never had it so
good well it knows narrow senses yes and
dad there's not that narrow is it
science medicine football's got a lot
better as well people play a fluid
attacking game now it's terrific
but look things you know what would be
mad to say that nothing has got better
that would be an insane proposition and
I can't believe that that that
intelligence squared would come up with
it my my point is that there are a
number of things we have lost as a
consequence of the economic system we're
failing the the the the the consequence
of the economic system that we're
following one of them is social mobility
any pretense of social mobility which
was at least present it at least gave my
parents and and my parents friends in
there in the fifties and sixties the the
the suspicion that they might be able to
make their way in the world and compete
on an equal basis with with with the F
alone that's gone I mean that that has
just disappeared and the other thing
which is gone is that we've we've sort
of given up on the on the communitarian
aspect of the the thing which really
holds society together which is you know
that we look out for each other that
seems to have gone as well though I
think it's very very very nice and
undoubtedly a step forward that rachel
has met a working-class person the III
hope she was as thrilled
you did open yourself up to that and you
want to discreetly come back on that
Rachel Johnson I think the rod sort of
is defeating his own argument by saying
that mental health is a redirect result
of affluenza and then critiquing our
side of the room of the panel for saying
yes we are all better off we do have
more material possessions we do have
better health service we do have a
welfare state as if none of this makes
any difference to the comfort and our of
our lives and the prospects for our
children I think it's just utterly
self-defeating well it's argument will
self just come back on that one point
you wanted to pick up I mean the risk on
mental health and tolerance I mean yes
and and yeah no I mean we live in a very
interested culture in terms of mental
health I did a program for the BBC last
year on on selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitors such as Prozac and other
antidepressants 20 million prescriptions
are written in this country every year I
went into researching that documentary
feeling that probably these drugs would
rather over prescribed you know that
probably they were being handing out to
people you know like rod picked up on to
the worried well or two people who had
general stress and anxiety what I
discovered and I say this in the full
knowledge that statistically there will
be a large number of people in this room
taking these drugs was that these drugs
do not work that the people who devised
and sell them can give no explanation
for their effects upon the individuals
who take them that the so-called
chemical theory of depression is
absolutely baseless and that in all
likelihood the reason why people feel
some amelioration from depression and
taking them is because of bad side
effects that the drugs are giving them
now to live in a society to relation no
no wait a minute to this is a very
important point about science and our
faith in science to live in a society
because I don't doubt that the people
who take SSRIs do feel better that's the
paradox
but they feel better
because of their belief and what are
they believing in they're believing in a
kind of scientism and a kind of
reduction of themselves to chemical
units that is the very opposite of a
soulful and embodied existence so no
wonder more and more prescriptions get
written okay thank you I'm okay I'm
aware of the question I'm aware of the
question about immigration I'm going to
return to that subject let's take
another round of contributions here the
lady up there I know you're gonna be
next and if we have another microphone
here yeah um do you think that the
motion that we've never had it so good
creates and perpetuates complacency and
stagnation within society shouldn't we
always be striving for a better tomorrow
today rather than downplaying the
achievements of those before us thank
you thank you and just to explain there
was a woman there and she moved away and
he asked the question in space so that
contribution here yeah it's a question
for especially what little actually and
many people including myself
increasingly feel that inequality is
probably the most divisive thing and the
most harmful thing going on in our
society what can we the downtrodden and
powerless do about it
so you said those last few words again I
just miss the weight loss what can we
the downtrodden and powerless do about
it about inequality thank you
question-there
hi I think throughout the talk we've
been referring to we as in sort of the
UK and talking about just this country
and today Bill and Melinda Gates wrote a
very interesting essay which was in The
Wall Street Journal and I just wanted to
refer to that because they were talking
about the world as a whole by almost any
measure the world has never been better
off as the world is better off now than
it has ever been before
extreme poverty has been cut in half
over the past 25 years and then they
went on to disprove three myths one that
incomes and other measures of human
welfare everywhere including the trump
card of Africa have gotten better
foreign aid has saved lives and laid the
groundwork for
seeing long-term economic progress
despite all the corruption that is
involved with foreign aid and lastly
that despite people's fears that
medicine and lowering the risk of
childbirth will lead to overpopulation
it has only led to people having smaller
families because families of in Thailand
its 1.6 children to every family okay so
your evidence from the Gates Foundation
that the global picture it shows
improvement yet questionnaire here my
questions mainly on will cells points he
says that we shouldn't be arguing about
consumerism and we should be talking
about the soul but arguably on that
point of view we've never had it so good
he could he could stand up and introduce
himself as an agnostic I came here I saw
Daniel Dennett's he's a famous atheist a
hundred years ago you can do that people
who wanted those views or who had those
views were being burned at the stake
going back only a few hundred years
nowadays people go to yoga and
meditation learn far more about
spirituality so arguably on a spiritual
basis we've never had it so good thank
you
I've nature's most of these questions
are one more another ending up being
addressing this side of the table if
anybody got a question to put or a
challenge to put to these two yeah we've
got a few hands there if we can get keep
your hand up if you all want to
challenge these two here and we'll hear
from you and then we're gonna bring that
yeah again then we'll try to give it to
you as oh yeah hello
from the side of the table for the
notion I've heard a lot about
materialism consumerism how we've had it
well we're having it really good at the
moment in those sons but is that
sustainable in the future and isn't
gonna get better
we'll stay good or is it gonna get worse
sustainable you mean environmental yes
and also in a moral sense okay thank you
and if you pass the microphone along I
just bring it down here thank you very
much that's great I think we'll then
bring it back office yes hello and I'd
first like to say to Rachel Johnson well
done and congratulations for trying to
put living on three pounds a would you
say a day for food for hope one pound
one pound a day for a whole family in a
good light must have been very difficult
however although you experienced a week
of this it's alright for you to go home
at the end of the week because you don't
have to live through that
so there's been a big focus on mental
health I have to say as I've experienced
mental health and mental health services
have to say they are absolutely [ __ ]
forgive my language it is disgusting I I
was learning about the suffragettes
today and I had to remind my teacher to
her horror that people still do get to
fete like the suffragettes who went on
hunger strikes dead people do still get
put in straightjackets people do still
get sedated if they are being too out of
order so I can't believe yeah maybe it's
been better but it's just not good
enough it's absolutely not good enough
so we've never had it so good that's
absolute [ __ ] okay we'll take a very
large social one from here and then
we're gonna I was actually gonna ask
something entirely different but just to
the in response to that last question we
may not have had it he may have been
mentally great now but surely it was
considerably worse in the past sure we
still have straitjackets and some people
still too fed but previously you were
burnt at the stake and I suffer I suffer
mental knows in the past I would have
been burned at the stake too I think
it's just about as good if you've ever
had it and does the panel agree
okay thank you we've now got a range of
questions to bring to everyone here so
let's put that to you first of all
Rachel Johnson the idea that it was all
right for you your experience with
living on a pound a day and seeing
families feeding themselves on three
pounds a week rather three times a week
in a pound a day in your case but you
could walk away at the end of that
experience they can't yeah well I never
claimed I wasn't I'm not unbelievably
unspeakably privileged and of course I
knew that after a week I was going to go
home and that's what made it possible
and the whole point of the exercise was
to bring to public attention something
that people do not know which is that
there exists genuine food poverty in the
in this country as a result of and we're
talking about food banks earlier think
you don't
well Rossiter how many food banks do you
think there are you don't know she's
also do you question how many food banks
oh I don't know okay five hundred
thousand people are using food banks and
the number has gone up by eleven for a
fall near mean an affluent plant a tent
okay let's say you've only you've made
that part of and I'm also being
challenged on mental health and I think
it's just to you personally was it well
I don't think it was just to you it was
just services it improve I think it's a
it's a testament to the fact that we are
much more open about mental health in
this country that you could stand up in
front of 800 people and talk about your
own experience and I that wouldn't have
happened even 20 years ago
so congratulations I hope you get the
help you need and I'm sorry about the
experiences you had every single family
in Britain has some sort of mental
health issue going on in it we're all
aware of that it's not no longer a dark
secret you've you've addressed it don't
worry we've got other people I want to
include the will self put to you this
point out religious tolerance because
you do you were trying to speak on a
non-material non-economists ik plane and
there's a question is saying that you
could be open about agnosticism and
people can be there's a much greater
variety and pluralism and tolerance of
difference spiritually religiously etc
and surely that represents an advance
well I mean as long as you subscribe to
the religion of neoliberalism you're
absolutely fine as long as you believe
as this gentleman does that the rich
getting endlessly richer is the only way
to guarantee that the poor will get rich
or as well if you're a if you're a
heretic from that state inculcated
religion you're in quite a lot of
trouble but we don't know how people
felt in the Geneva of Calvin or in the
Germany of Luther when they experienced
the liberty of consciousness conscience
that came with Protestantism we don't
know how people felt sitting under the
Bodhi tree when they heard the guitar
MERS message you're not a part of the
job is to a man i empathize isn't it
twopence pickle self in those people
shows that happen say Jonathan
you know do you get out the bed and put
on a prosaic suit I have a sense of the
line you've used before let me ask you
Robert it is not and I assure you I just
coined it in my capacity as a novelist
but very let me say this and I and I say
it with a spirit of passion I ask you to
reject this motion not because I don't
think there are great things about the
society not because I'm a happy person
not a happy person because I am quite a
happy person not because I don't think
there's fabulous things all around us
but because lots of that way of viewing
the world I believe is impoverishing
it's impoverishing for you and it's
impoverishing for us as a society it's
just the wrong way of looking at things
that's all
OK ROCK rod I just wanted slowing us
down a bit but rod little--just I want
you to address the the questionnaire at
the back there the woman who mentioned
the evidence on the Gates Foundation on
through at least three different
measures you know the global picture is
improved and that poverty extreme
poverty global is down by half according
to those figures the evidence she was
suggesting says the global picture at
least has got better as the global
picture according to hunger and and
malnutrition has certainly got better
yes we are now in in danger of of more
people dying as a consequence of a beef
of obesity and obesity related diseases
than are now dying of malnutrition which
I suppose is a sort of step forward they
call it a nutrition now is yes us word
in global health statistics about you
know again I I wouldn't I wouldn't
descend from that my point is we're
talking about you have we have never had
it so good we I talked to me in us and I
think he look inside us I tried to do
what we'll probably rightly I said we
couldn't do which is to look inside the
soles of us and we don't seem to be
terribly happy by every means that I
have available to look at this country
we do not seem to be happy
one more point on from the it from the
other chap who asked what can we do
about inequality well join the Labour
Party as you know probably the best I
can offer but also job didn't work out
that well for inequality did it I'm not
terribly well no no absolutely [ __ ]
nightmare and fair point but if EE a
doubling of the minimum wage wouldn't
come amiss that's why all those firms
are coming back come up a lot is charity
yeah you know Thomas Hobbes the
philosopher said charity exists to
lighten the burden of compassion in the
wealthy man we now live in a society
that is dominated Rachel went on about
the big society doubtless Jessie did as
well I ask you do you really want to
live in a society that is you know
determined by the charitable impulse in
this way all you hear about is charity
charity charity Red Nose Day red butter
Day red genitals day give your money and
this in a society with greater
inequality greater wealth inequality
than they've been for decades okay is
there not a correlation there thank you
great little starved herself the charity
thank you let's see we're gonna start
because of where where we are with the
clock we're going to start the voting
now I'm hoping people I'm gonna try and
get more questions in if I can but at
times against us we are you're see our
friends are walking around now with
ballot boxes you've got the cards you
using the perforation break the card
either a yes goes in or no goes in or if
you are on the fence in your abstaining
putting the whole card
this is Shh this is a secret ballot and
as I've mentioned before a silent ballot
there is no need for you to speak while
you're voting because that we're now
going to hear closing arguments from our
speakers there's not much they can do to
shift your view because you will be
voting but let's say in reverse order
here closing arguments and that means a
minute or two to you Jesse Norman
so sorry and rod riffle is going to go
first love little you already did
address this point about what people can
do about it but perhaps a more on that
if you can in the in your closing
remarks and address anything else that's
on this issue of what people can do
about the inner quality you've described
your variety anything leave just Riya
policy so here we are
you've got a couple of minutes to
closing arguments on the whole thing rod
a little okay so stain your chest energy
oh I like it here Phil in charge this
reject this motion at least partly
because that phrase you've never had it
so good together with its bastard kids
sister
we're all in it together is used by that
lot to perpetuate the inequalities which
are making this country less than it
could be and it's less than it could be
which is the problem it's less than it
could be as will says spiritually but
also as I would put it we are less happy
about who we are about what we are and
we're less happy for bloody good reasons
that these inequalities exist that we're
consumer-led and consumer-driven
that we've lost something about our
lives which is the way we relate to
other people because of an atomized or
existence or an enemy as Durkheim would
have put it that is invaded us and is a
direct consequence and is necessary to
the economic policies which Jesse
Norman's party follows and which indeed
to its eternal shame Tony Blair's party
followed as well so reject the motion on
political grounds as well as on
spiritual grounds thank you
let's get a closing remark from you
Rachel Johnson and you alright if
everyone's gonna do that you might as
well why don't you address if you can
this notion that is it sustainable you
said all these the numbers are all going
up but is it sustainable both
economically environmentally but also
morally well I don't want to I don't
want to answer that Jonathan I would I
don't care how you vote I think you
should you should vote for the motion
it's unbelievably gloomy reductive and
pessimistic if you don't we've had it
good and it's it's our duty not to
regard the world as getting worse all
the time but to pass it on better to
make sure it's better rather than just
assume it's getting worse the charity
sector don't knock the charity sector
will it is desperately needed I'm not
going to go on about my starvation or
benefits treat against I'm getting such
a lot of stick for it don't you you just
wait will you just wait
the reason we're unhappy is not because
we've got too little it's because we've
got too much choice material goods
people unhappiness and depression is
much more a first-world problem than you
this side is letting on in and is
acknowledging just on a lighter note
just think of this in terms of coffee
and my lifetime Coffee has gone from a
watery fluid that looked and taste like
Bovril to roasty-toasty bespoke beverage
that you can get from the push of a
button in your own kitchen
don't knock this this is this is a
material advantage it has made all our
lives better every one of us in this
room anyway to fight to sum up as
Macaulay said on what principle is it we
are not we see nothing but improvement
behind us but we are to expect nothing
but deterioration before us I beg you to
reject the box set of doom that we've
heard from will and rod amusing though
they are
please do not believe in the audacity of
nope
or of dope which is what we'll was
talking about in terms of Prozac I beg
you to support the motion thank you
some closing remarks from you will self
I love to walk often across the city I
once flew to Los Angeles and walked for
eight days around LA without ever
stepping in a wheeled vehicle people say
you can't walk in LA it's a beautiful
city to walk in unlike an English
suburbia the Los Angelenos tend to do
all their difference of urban houses in
different wacky architectural styles and
there are nice broad sidewalks it's
sunny the whole time but I also like
walking across London free to walk just
breathe walk think meditate I really
really urge you to get out and have a
decent walk preferably to a random
destination one that is not economically
compelled that's really all I have to
say to you be happy
live long prosper one other thing you
may notice that the supporters of this
motion both promoted books either by
them or by their siblings
and I should have promoted one by him
and I failed to mention that he is his
latest book is called umbrella and I
also failed to mention this between pay
perfectly well to do this I don't
require to come along with a little
stool around my name you don't but I'm
not plugging you stuff on top of it
unlike the materialists on there you've
already done it you've already done it
we're not gonna let you do it again now
price point at $17.99 which no consumer
thinks is anywhere near 18 pounds Jesse
Norman you're it falls to you to give us
to give us the last word your fellow
debater refused to answer the question
that we hadn't been put by me but have
been put by one of our members of our
audience who said it's is it sustainable
morally and ecologically and there was
also a dissenting note from someone in
the audience who said you know even if
it is better now shouldn't we always
strive to make life even better and
therefore not be complacent enough to
say we've never had it so good so if you
would deal with those two questions that
have come from our audience members all
the better
Jesse Norman Jove that's a wonderful
attempt to tie me to your agenda but if
it's okay with you I'll give a closing
speech that actually addresses the
defects of our opposition's comments um
you would have noticed a gentleman
how triumphantly they fulfilled every
caricature that one could possibly have
wanted for most holistic pessimistic
gloom stirring lugubrious issues um but
lurking underneath this farrago of
misdirection was a couple of points that
might just be worth picking up first of
all I was amused I'm sure you enchanted
to see um rod defending the Labour
government's position on inequality
since it had roughly speaking the
largest amount of money that's ever been
had by any British government that could
have been used to assuage it and yet
real wages for the bottom third of this
country did not rise after 2003 let's
put that thought in your mind um and
former Prime Minister Blair rod I'm sure
looking forward to your explanation we
weren't here it's sadly because the
moment is past of how Mr Blair can run
off around the world enriching himself
on the back of his international call
[Music]
well what's the expand realize will was
most magnificent but tragically
magnificent and is incoherent some it
would've been a wonderful to address the
issue it's not a point of contention
between our two sides I absolutely agree
that this country in many ways has
become more individualistic and more
economic and our politics has become
more individualistic and more
economistic than we have any right to
want or expect that's completely
consistent with the position that we are
taking the question ultimately is this
Immanuel Kant that great figure says we
live under the regulative Hope of that
our lives can be lived free freely and
with a you know in a moral community
that gives them their points and their
purpose and at the end of the day you
either feel positively about the
situation about the fact that we've laid
out before you which are pretty
dispositive but about how we're supposed
to think about them how am I supposed to
interpret them you either think the
glass is half-full and we can go on and
make better these moral and spiritual
defects that are so obvious in our
society the mode or you think there's
nothing to be done and we can just cross
our hands put our hands heads down and
forget about it and I put it to you that
that simply isn't an adequate position
we have to get up there we have to do
something about it it's our obligation
to do that and I put it to you ladies
and gentlemen that we must reject that
we reject that false gloom and with it
reject this hopeless opposition and
accept the motion thank you very much
indeed
[Applause]
I don't know about we've never had it so
good but we don't yet have it the result
of your vote but it's coming in seconds
and so while we wait for that you you
just were shaking your head will self at
the notion of you as an embodiment of
lugubrious City and other things thrown
at you you want to just come back at
just normal call dear all and tralala i
smite him with my pig's bladder also
sounded like he was campaigning for
votes when he was up there
no he mischaracterized what rod and i
have been saying we never suggested that
people shouldn't you know strive to make
things better did we we never suggested
anyway the motion doesn't propose that
you're a glass-half-full or a glass half
half empty type of person it proposes
that everybody in the country feels they
have some sort of psychic bumper full of
vintage Bollinger that they're lifting
to their lips and that clearly isn't the
case so you know I must protest most
vigorously not only that Jesse Norman is
not a large black woman who sings
beautifully but a book but a thin white
man who dresses rather boringly but but
that he willfully mischaracterizes what
rod and I have been saying and Ward
dear rod you know I used to work for rod
at the Today program and I would never
be happier than I and I saw his rubicund
and at that time youthful face looking
at me across the desks full of tedious
BBC hacks here was a man out on a limb
here was a man dancing on the high wire
here was a happy man a happy man
excellent thank you thank you
that slightly felt like a round of just
a minute and brilliantly you've talked
us up to the imaginary whistle and I can
tell you now the final result when you
came in those of you who would don't
knows and on the fence stood at twenty
nine percent that number has cratered to
just three percent so these four
speakers have done a great job of
shifting you now the figures stand as
follows those of you who are for the
motion that we've never had it so good
whereas you came in forty seven percent
now stand at thirty seven percent those
of you who are against the motion and
believe that no we have not never had it
so good or rather just you disagree with
we've never had it so good
stand that 60 percent
the motion is defeated
the motion is defeated then the motion
is defeated are you've already done it
but let's thank finally in our remaining
moments our four brilliant speakers
Jesse Norman Rachel Johnson will soften
riddle thank you very much
[Applause]